[Music]
if you haven't seen season 9 episode 5
of The Walking Dead then you need to
turn off now those who have however will
be aware that the show has had another
massive time jump that allowed Judith
Grimes to age about five years and
become a better shot than bullseye the
ending scene of the episode also made
several new characters the focus and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the new survivors in full detail there
are potential spoilers for the comic
book and show here so if you don't want
anything room for you that I suggest you
turn off and howl without the way I'm
definition and I roon it so you don't
have to Magne the first person that we
need to pay attention to is Magne the
group's leader she's pretty much the
female version of brick and makes sense
to become his replacement she escaped
walkers on horseback by herself run into
survivors and formed a group the
character is of Greek descent but
outside of this very little is known
about her past
Magne is instrumental in the war of the
whisperers and this is most likely where
the show will utilize the character in
the future
Yumiko Yumiko is probably my favourite
character from the bunch
she's pretty much a female Darrell and
his Magnus most trusted ally the two are
in a relationship together and Yumiko
gods the former with their life wielding
a bow she is able to silently take our
walkers and whisperers with ease and I
can definitely see the show doing a lot
of cool things with Luke
whilst Luke doesn't play a huge part in
the comics the next bit about him could
potentially spoil a huge segment of the
future of the show so I highly recommend
that he skip this section if you don't
care then we'll go right ahead but in
the comics Luke is killed by alpha who
infiltrates Rick's camp disguised as one
of them she lures people away from the
camp and Begins for heading them placing
their heads on pikes to mark the border
between her people and Rick's Luke is
one of the people who gets beheaded and
there's a fantastic panel in the comm
where we see his head skewered on a pipe
it's a huge moment that I really hope
wasn't spoiled for you but if it was
what can I say I warned you please don't
sneak into my house and behead me as a
warning not to spoil anything in future
thank you very much
Connie Connie is a huge game changer for
the show as she's the first deaf main
character to appear in it she
communicates through American Sign
Language but obviously her lack of
hearing makes it difficult for her to
survive in the situations that the
walkers and whisperers provide Connie is
bitten during a whisper attack and has
to have her hand amputated which leads
to further tension with the character
though she recovers from the amputation
and makes her survival even more
difficult and the stakes really rise for
her every time she's put in danger Kelly
the final character is Kelly and they're
definitely the most departed from the
source material in the comic books Kelly
is a man and is in a relationship with
Connie whereas the show seems to have
departed from this massively and the two
are now sisters I can't see them hooking
up unless the Walking Dead really wants
to go the Game of Thrones route who
knows in the zombie field apocalypse
that they live in Kelly is the one who
amputates Connie's hand and I can
definitely see this being something
that's brought into the show even if the
rest of the character isn't so what are
your thoughts on the new characters in
The Walking Dead do you think they'll
make a good replacement for Rick and
what would you like to see them do in
the future
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of Rick's
final episode which will be linked at
the end of this one this is a channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you